do you ever question the nature of your
reality are you real or are you a
product of some complex computer
simulation what I'm about to tell you
might change the way you perceive the
world and it all starts with a cosmic
mega structure the size of our solar
system this is what if and here's what
would happen if we could build a
Matuschka brain we've talked about
cosmic mega structures before but this
one isn't like any other to understand
what a matroyshka brain is and how it
could change your outlook on life we
need to start from the beginning a Dyson
Sphere in 1960 a physicist and a seeker
for alien life Freeman Dyson came up
with the idea that advanced
extraterrestrial civilizations would
build space mega structures around their
host star they do it to collect all of
their star's energy and fuel their
travels across the universe or they
simply use the structure as real-estate
location location location
then almost 50 years later an inventor
by the name of Robert Bradbury gave new
meaning to Dyson spheres according to
his calculations by the year 2250
humanity would become advanced enough to
start building a mega structure similar
to the one proposed by Dyson but instead
of having just one sphere around the Sun
we'd stack them around one another just
like the Russian matryoshka dolls
what materials would we need to build a
structure like that how far into the
solar system would our construction
stretch and most importantly what would
we be using this matroyshka brain for
we'd start with a single Dyson Sphere
we've used this first shell
to draw the energy from the Sun a Dyson
Sphere would give us so much solar
energy that it would be enough to power
the most advanced computer in the
universe I told you amateurish cob rain
isn't just any mega structure we could
live on
it's a giant supercomputer the size of
the solar system the shells of the
matroyshka brain would expand from the
orbit of mercury beyond the orbit of
Neptune they'd be passing energy from
the Sun down to the last outer shell
we'd have robots mine Venus for its
rocky silicate mantle until there's
nothing left of it but silicon isn't the
only thing we'd need for this
construction the shells of the
matroyshka brain would be made of a
material called computronium it's a
hypothetical material we've yet to
invent but the idea behind it is that
every particle would be a tiny computer
capable of passing computer codes to
other particles the matroyshka brain
would start writing its own code
building itself and expanding far into
the solar system it would be capable of
calculating and predicting every event
from human interactions to cosmic
occurrences it's processing power would
have no limits at all
okay all this talk about electronic
brain made me want to learn a little bit
more about computers so I went to our
friends at brilliant and read about how
computers learn and store data even
though they see the world brilliant has
a collection of interactive courses
daily challenges quizzes and a whole lot
more
they make learning fun and if I have to
stay home any longer I might start the
course on computer programming and
change my job and you should try it to
go to brilliant dot org slash what-if
and sign up for free and if you hurry
and you're among the first 200 people to
get to that link you'll get 20% off the
annual premium subscription that means
unlimited access to every brilliant
interactive course including computer
science and the math behind gymnastics
alright let's get back to our macro sure
brain what would it mean for us to have
unlimited computing power how would we
use it building a mega structure like
this would make us a type two
civilization on the Kardashev scale it's
a scale that characterizes civilizations
by their energy disposal level a type
one civilization is one that's tamed all
of its planet's resources and can
control the weather
earthquakes even volcanoes a type two
civilization can harvest all the energy
of its host star with all the energy of
the Sun at our disposal we could become
intergalactic travelers yeah we could
leave our solar system and go explore
what's out there we could relocate to
other planets if we wanted but most
likely that's not where we'd end up with
the computational power of the matroska
brain we could simulate an alternate
digital reality we could leave our
physical bodies behind and upload our
brains into that virtual world
we've become a new species immortal
entities with unlimited computing
abilities we create our own universes
with our own rules or maybe we'd
recreate our world and control every
aspect of it that said how can you tell
if you aren't already inside I'm at risk
of rain right doesn't this make you
question your entire reality our world
might already be a computer simulation
in which we're nothing more than
computer code but that's a story or
another
[Music]
you